>> HEY.
I'M SETH.
I'M THE BIRTHDAY CLOWN.
SORRY I CAME EARLY.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
DID YOU FIND PARKING OKAY?
>> I TOOK AN UBER?
>> DRESSED LIKE THIS?
>> IT'S PART OF THE JOB.
I'M USED TO IT.
>> SET UP HERE.
YOU HAVE TO GET A BETTER
DEFENSE.
>> IT HAS BEEN A GOOD SEASON.
WHERE IS THE BIRTHDAY BOY.
LITTLE ERNIE.
>> THAT'S ME.
I'M ERNIE.
IT'S MY BIRTHDAY.
>> SO -- DO YOU WANT -- SHOULD
WE WAIT FOR EVERYONE TO SHOW UP.
>> NO, IT'S JUST ME.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
>> I'M SORRY.
BEFORE I START, I'M WONDERING
WHY --
>> I HAVE TO TAKE MY MIND OFF
SOME STUFF.
>> YEAH.
OKAY.
SURE.
YEAH.
I'M JUST GOING TO DO IT.
♪♪♪
>> HEY, KIDS.
ARE YOU READY FOR DO DO THE
CLOWN?
>> UH-HUH.
>> I CAN'T HEAR YOU.
>> YEAH, I'M READY.
>> NOW HERE COMES DO DO!
>> CUTE.
>> HEY, KIDS.
DO YOU REMEMBER MY NAME?
>> DO DO.
>> AND WHAT'S YOUR NAME,
BIRTHDAY BOY?
>> ERNIE SULLIVAN.
>> HOW OLD ARE YOU TURNING
TODAY?
>> I'M 53.
>> WHAT'S YOUR FAVORITE COLOR?
>> UM, I DON'T KNOW.
>> OKAY.
UM, BOY I SURE AM HUNGRY.
I HOPE I GOT A SNACK!
>> THAT'S PRETTY FUNNY.
HERE YOU GO.
>> YOU GIVING ME A TIP?
>> YOU WANT ME TO WAIT UNTIL
AFTER.
>> THERE IS NO PROTOCOL FOR
WHATEVER THIS IS.
>> GO AHEAD.
EXCUSE ME.
>> YOU WANT ME TO STOP AND WAIT?
>> NO, I CAN SEE FROM HERE.
KEEP GOING.
HEY, CAN YOU GET THAT?
>> WE ARE HERE FOR LITTLE
ERNIE'S BIRTHDAY PARTY.
>> YOU DON'T WANT THIS.
I THINK I SHOULD GO TOO.
>> YEAH, MAN.
LISTEN, I'M SORRY.
I TRY TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT
FOR MY BIRTHDAY.
IT GOT WEIRD.
>> NO.
IT'S OKAY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
>> THANK YOU.
CAN YOU COME INTO THE KITCHEN
FOR A MINUTE?
>> YEAH.
WHAT'S UP.
>> I'M GOING TO CHOP YOU UP IN
LITTLE PIECES AND PUT YOU IN THE
FRIDGE.
>> SEEMS ABO